foreign
[Music]
a couple of people have been doing that
here San Ysidro Port of Entry with the
summer upon us we have high traffic a
lot of crossers so we're seeing an
increase of narcotic smuggling people
smuggling
oh
foreign
played a big role with human smuggling
most of our Smugglers are tourists that
come from Mexico so when they were
restricted from entering the country
during the pandemic a lot of
organizations looked towards United
States citizens to try and smuggle
people
hi good morning
we have people crossing every day 99 of
those people they're legitimate travel
but we have people that will get
documents in Mexico either they buy the
documents or they steal the documents
and they present themselves as that
person hi welcome the camera so this
facial recognition system is an extra
layer of enforcement for us to determine
one that the person is the person that
she is presenting do you mind just
taking the mask off we're going to take
a picture and also help us determine the
citizenship when they present a U.S
passport
okay
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
driver's license as their identification
and we did a Biometrics picture
comparison the picture did not match the
picture that she previously has with her
U.S passport so she was referred to
secondary so we can verify that that's
the person that we didn't
how are you ma'am okay have you had a
U.S passport
are okay all right what happened to your
passport
okay
um
[Music]
she was very straightforward always
looking at me she didn't hesitate on
responding when we told her that we were
going to take the fingerprint
that's usually a sign that a person is
being truthful
fingerprint and we collaborate that it
was her
thank you for your cooperation and
you're good to go okay yeah have a good
one
[Music]